hello everyone welcome to this demo in
this demo we are going to talk about it
how exactly we can do the installation
of
maven so first of all we'll do it on the
windows platform here and we'll see that
how the installation really works
so for this one i will be doing the
installation into my local system
now before even going for maven maven is
in kind of a build tool which is
available there
primary for performing any kind of build
automation for the java based projects
now since it's used for java we also
require the jdk installation onto our
system
so for that both of the installations we
will be covering over here
and we'll see that how the installation
really works as such over here
right so before even going for maven we
have to install
the jdk onto our windows machine so that
we can proceed with maven because maven
requires
the jdk installations to be there now
there are two ways of getting
installation either you go for the exe
file
or you extract the binaries of jdk to a
directory and then
set up the java underscore home path for
that but if you are using the executable
that will perform the path
configurations for you also so in that
case you don't have to reconfigure it
again and again
so that's what we are going to see here
so first of all we will try to do the
installation of jdk so for that we'll go
to the website of jdk and then we have
to click on this one
to access the maven installations part
here
so that's what we are going to do so
let's proceed and let's open the chrome
and try to go through these
two urls so that we can do the
installations one by one
so here i have to just search for jdk8
download so it will show me the url for
oracle.com
so here you will get the jdk for the
different platforms for different
operating systems
now here what you can see here that you
have the configurations
in which you have the jdk installation
so we have to
so here i'll go for the windows 64
version because that is something
i will be using to do the installation
so
this is the complete executable link so
here you can download so
we are downloading the sdk a u251 so
just search for windows 64 yeah this is
the one so
let me click on this one
let me quickly log into the web page so
once the login is done you will be able
to see
that it's trying to download the exe
file so
that was for the jdk for the java now
for the maven
i am going to go for the maven download
over here
so in this one the maven repo link is
there maven.apache.org is the link for
this one
now here we have the different options
you can see here that uh the
binaries if like archive is there then
sources
archive is there so depending on the
installation which you want to perform
you should be able to download that file
and it works there
so let's first install the jdk portion
and then we'll go with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because uh it's something we
have to anyways do it so we'll click on
this
so that this maven is also getting
started install or downloading over here
so once both of them are downloaded
we will proceed further with the setup
so let's wait for
another one minute to do this one
so the apache maven is kind of
downloaded over here so we
wait for the jdk download also over here
so next 5 10 seconds only left out
so first jdk will be there and then
maven installation configurations will
be there so
for me when we just have to extract into
a directory and give the mvn home path
into the properties uh into the variable
so that it can pick it up
over there okay so we have to extract
the zip file from a1
give the path and then we will check
with the maven command whether it's
working fine or not
so let's try to install the executive so
we'll open the directory where the
executables are there so first of all
we'll install the jdk
so we'll double click the installer for
jdk itself for around 200 mb
so the complete jdk will be installed so
we have to just go for
next now when you go with the installer
so usually the
java home parts and all that stuff is
already configured so
you don't really have to change the
passwords or java home
any kind of variable you have to put it
up all those things will be
automatically
cleaned up
it's running the installation
close so then we have to extract the
maven so we have to extract this
directory because
here the maven complete executables and
libraries are there so we just have to
extract it and place into a directory so
that
we can further on uh use it and access
the path so
once the access is done
yep so this is done there so i can
rename it to
like maven so i can rename it like to
ask me one
and i can cut it down and put it into
the c drive here
now this is the maven home path which is
going to be there
right so all i have to do is that i have
to close this one and
this one and this one and this
so what we have to do is that we have to
really go to the system properties
so that we can extract it so i'm going
to open the
system properties over here
properties now here the advanced system
settings
now in this one we will be setting up
the paths the environment variable will
go
now here if you scroll down you will see
all the different parts which is
available there as such over here
now if we want to see that if the java
is fine or we require for jdk also
so all we have to do is that we have to
open the cmd prompt
window r we are providing so using the
window r i'm opening the
run window where i can say like cmd now
in the cmd i'm going to say like
java hyphen version so java is there so
which means that we don't have any
problem as such
now i'll just go here and set up a new
one called
mvn underscore home so here the same
path so you can browse for directory
also but i am using the ambient home
over here in this one
now i have just added that and in the
path variable
in the last we have to actually add the
bin directory also so that uh whenever
we run the
mvn command so that should also be
resolved so mvn
underscore home is not the only variable
which you will be configuring
in fact you will be confirming the path
variable also that you can go ahead and
put up a new directory
entry for the cmd here so cmd
till the cmd directory you will go there
and whatever the executable is there you
should be able to resolve that
so for that again you have to open the
window are cmd prompt java
hyphen version and then you can run mvn
hyphen version here when you run the mvn
hyphen version
it will let you know that which
particular java runtime you are using
1.8.0 underscore 251 that's the same one
which we have configured
and it also let us know that where
exactly the executable is there and we
can now proceed further with the
execution
of the maven build so you just have to
check out your source code
or go to the directory where source code
is there and you can run the mvn clean
install so that will
ultimately go for the build process so
this is the way that how we can do the
installation of
maven on the windows platform now since
this is done now we will go ahead with
the second installation where we are
going to
do the installation of maven and jdk
onto the
open to machine so for that we will log
into the particular cloud lab of
simply learn lms so let's log into the
lms here
so now we are going to do uh the
installation of uh
jdk and maven on the ubuntu virtual
machine here so for that we will log
into the lms so let's
log into that so this is the uh elements
over here here i have already started
the lab here so all i have to do is that
i have to just click on this
link here so it will open the lab into a
new tab it's a gui mode of ubuntu server
so which we will be using to configure
it
so uh here first of all i can open the
chrome browser also so let me open the
browser here so that i can download the
maven executables as such over here
so jdk we can do it using the package
installation so
uh using the app executable we will be
doing the installation so i
have to just open the terminal here so
once the terminal is opened
you have to log in through the root id
now why we require root id
so that we should be able to do the
package installations and other
configurations
so that requires root access
now once that is done you have to run
the particular
app update command next you have to
install the installer so
the oracle installer we have to install
now uh once the
setup is done so let's down install the
latest package
over here for ico oracle hyphen java 14
hyphen installation so this will install
the
jk 14 over here so for that
configurations
now at the same time we'll go for maven
download also
so here uh we'll go for download maven
so this is the tar file for executables
i'm going to copy this
url here and over here
we'll say yes yes
yes so now uh the java should be
configured and could
uh should be set up over here in this
one so what we really need to do is that
we need to run the java command to see
that if the installation is done
properly or not
so uh let's open the terminal again
another terminal so that i can
perform these steps related to maven so
i have got the url so i'm going to the
opt directory which is always an
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations
so i'm going to run the wget command and
then the url which i have downloaded
so this should uh download the tar file
over here of
maven now once that is like done so i
have to extract it
so uh tar hyphen xv zf and the tar file
name this is a targenzip file so i have
to use
tar hyphen xp zf parameter over here to
extract it
now uh what exactly i have got i have
got the apache maven directory over here
so i am going to rename it
in order to rename it what we need to do
we need to actually go for
uh the particular move command so move
whatever the existing folder you have
and then i'm going to rename it with the
maven directory
now once that is done i'm going to the
maven directory and this
is the path or maven underscore home
path which is available
as such over here in this one so here
all the bin directories executables all
this stuff is there
so now i can use it like mv underscore
home and the same configuration just
like we did in the window
so here also it the same process we have
to follow
so java hyphen version should be let me
know that which version is deployed so
14.01
version is deployed over here so for
java i do not don't have to set up the
path again here because i'm viewing for
the installer so i don't have to set up
the path
right so for maven now what exactly i
have to do i have to
go to the etc profile d
now here i'm going to put up a
particular file
now here you can see that we have the
jdk
file here which means that the path
variables and everything is configured
as such over here
so you can see that java underscore home
path all these variables are copied here
so i'm going to also create a same file
similar to this one here but in this
case what i'm going to use it that i'm
going to remove some of the values
so i'm going to have some of the
parameters added so
in order to do it effectively i can do
the echo command
so that i can copy the things from here
and
i can simply put up into the file here
so i'm going to have the path
variable added up over here now why i'm
putting up the paths
because it's the same configuration
which we did over there also
so opt slash maven
slash pin so all the pin directory
should be added to the
specific path variable so i'm just
trying to create
a file called maven dot ss just like a
jdk dot
sh over here i'm also creating similar
kind of file over here called maven dot
sh
now i'm not going uh in the vi mode or
other editors because i just want to
make you
understand that how i'm copying it the
content i'm taking the jdk.sh as in
reference
and putting up the details over here in
this one and then i'm going to export
mvn underscore home over here which is
related to like opt slash
maven so this is what we are going to
put up over here
and then maven in the end me when this
is the file which you should be having
now why we are using it
because of the fact that it's being used
or it will be
utilized in such a way that you can
perform the changes or whatever
configurations you want to perform this
will
help you to set up the certain parts
like a path and ambient home so that you
can run these scripts as such over here
so i'm going to give the executable
permissions to this one
and that's it so now what exactly i have
to do is that i have to do the source
here
profile dot d
maven once that is done i will be able
to run the mvn hyphen version over here
and the jdk part is already open so it's
going to refer to that part
so this is the way that how we configure
the meven and the jdk
specifically on the ubuntu virtual
machine
so pretty much that's it for this demo
in this demo we primarily talked about
that how we can do the installation of
jdk and maven on windows
and how we can do the similar task on
the maven on the
ubuntu virtual machine also here so here
we are going to talk about it how we can
do for a specific setup where we can do
for the installation of maven in a mac
operating system
so let's see so there are two ways of
doing the installation here first is
through the
brew executable on the mac now this brew
utility on mac is just like
app or yum utility which is present in
most of the environments or
most of the platforms here but here we
are using this pro to do the
installation of maven on the mac
operating system
and again this next one is just in a
particular mechanism where you should be
able to
have these setup like you can download
the binaries from the apache website
and then you can export the m2
underscore home and the path variable
so that you can start using the maven
executable
so we'll talk about these things and
we'll see that how exactly
we can go for this setup so let's login
uh to a particular
machine or mac operating system so where
we will be able to do all this activity
so this is the mac system which we have
here now in this one what we are going
to do is that we are going to open the
terminal
so we are going to open a terminal here
so this is my terminal
so usually in mac you don't require any
other
mechanism so the inbuilt terminal is
more than sufficient for doing this
stuff because
it's similar to a linux based platform
here so i'm going to run the command
here so first of all i'll just double
check that if my brew executable is
working fine
so i'll just run the brew help command
to see that if my brew is
working fine as such over here in this
one now i have the
command called brew install so that is
the command which we need to use
now in this one we have to actually give
the specific package which we want to
install so we will say like brew install
maven so it will download the
uh specific executables on the
system from the website it will download
the
maven executables so it will take some
time but ultimately it's trying to
download it
under the particular tar file so you can
see here that it's
downloading the 3.6.3 tar file over here
so i can see that the installation is
done so the three point six point three
version should be installed over here
so when i do like maven uh mvn under
hyphen iphone version over here
so you can see that the uh 3.6.3 version
is deployed as such over here
now this is something which is done with
the purely command over here called brew
which really helps us to do any kind of
package installations
not only maven other packages also can
be installed pretty much with the help
of this executable
now in order to see the manual stuff
what we really need to do is that we
need to actually
clean this uh specific installation so
that i should i will be able to show you
the manual installation also over here
so what i'm going to do is that i'm
going to run the command called
brew uninstall maven so that
the maven should be removed from your
system so
we are just trying to remove the maven
from here and you can see that the maven
executable
is not working as such over here so
which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case
but why i have uninstalled here so that
i should be able to
go ahead and download some custom maven
over here in this one
so i have opened the browser here so
i'll go for the maven
executable so we'll go for maven
download so that
we should be able to download a specific
the
executable here so i'm going for this
directory so here uh 3.6.3 version same
is available here
so i'm going to download the bin.gz
which was
uh the file we have so this is also
a kind of a linux platform right so
that's the reason why
uh here the tar file should work
perfectly fine so here i'm going to the
opt directory where we can have all the
optionals
related packages so if it is not there
so i can create a directory called
slash opt so i can
log in with
root so if you don't have the root
access so you can go for the
applications
in the applications you can actually
create a directory called maven
so here i can go for maven
yeah so here we will be
downloading the var file here so the tar
dot ganji file we are downloading over
here so i'll
give the path here so once the var file
or w gate command i am using to do the
installation but
sometimes the wwk is not available so i
can go for the
brew install w get also if that package
is available on video the installation
will be done
so we'll try to do the installation
using grubluket so that we will be able
to get a tar file generated
or downloaded there are other ways also
you can download it
from the browser also yeah you can go to
the browser and
here you can actually click and download
it and then you can transfer it locally
to this uh specific directory also so
both the possibilities are there
but i'm just trying to download the
wkate command so that it will be easy
for me to do the setup and
to do the download over here so i'm
going to run the same command again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so i'm going to
extract it over here
so once the extraction is done so i'm
going to rename it like to apache
maven so that i should not have any kind
of versioning or these kind of
parameters over here and the apache dot
maven hyphen this star file i'm trying
to remove as such over here
so this is what i have got as an end
result over here
now this is the current directory in
which i have these uh applications and
these setups
going forward over here so if i run the
mvn hyphen fn version command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because
uh still i have extracted the tar file
but that is not the activity is not
complete
i have to exactly set up some
environment variables
so that i should be able to run this mvn
command so what i really need to do over
here is that we have to
export certain variables
application slash maven
apache ma1 so this is the home directory
which i'm trying to configure over here
and then next thing is that path
variable so i'm going to have
we are going to carry the path variable
with the folder
so i'm going to have the folder
structure here so
the bin directory we have to provide so
i'm going to
copy here and paste
and then i'm concatenated with the bin
here so now
my environment variables are established
so
my mvn hyphen iphone version command as
you can see here
is that you know it's being picked up
over here but it's saying that the
particular
java runtime is not available so i can
go for java
view install java so that should be
enough there to install a java package
there so
you can see that it says that it's
already installed so and up to date so
that's the reason why it's not able to
do the installation so i'm going to
reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related to java
should be formatted or should be
extracted over here right
so as you can see that uh here it's
saying that if you want to really use
the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this
so let's run that and uh then we can see
that
the particular executable of java
will also be find out over here so java
hyphen version showing that yes it's
available there
and now my command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the gdk was
already installed but the problem with
that is that since
it's installed into a particular
location so you have to actually
override your path value so that you
should be able to see in that directory
and find out the java executable
so that i have got by doing the
installation i got the command over
there
in the output saying that this is the
installation which is done and now you
just have to extract or you have to just
you know put that bar directory into the
specified
uh path variable and that's how you got
the maven and java both command lines
working over here
so this is how you will be doing the
maven installations all together
how the overall installation of maven
and the jdk
really works on mac operating system so
that's it for this demo thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here